pas moi
abondant dans mon papa qui nous regarde
toi c'est ce qui m'est égal nous emmener
à paris à deux pas de l'opéra garni pour
aller parler d'un nouveau format de soif
en y insérant aujourd'hui à paris ça
souffle je pense que c'est la fin du
vote un peu printanier du mexique à la
fin du côté printanier du mois de
février
je vous emmène donc aujourd'hui pour
aller rencontrer un constructeur vous
connaissez c'est huawei qui va présenter
une nouvelle version du smartphone
pliable on a déjà pu voir l'année
dernière et je pense ça va être
[Musique]
on venait d'arriver dans la salle va
relier d'un congrès à tanger pas ça
tombe pas cette table à tourner un peu
regardez il ya tout le monde a regardé
toutes les journalistes est plein de
monde j'ai vu passer plein de copains
j'ai entendu il faut que les gens
croient que fut vendu [ __ ] mais bon tu
dis ça mais qui c'est du harcèlement
mais ce grave dans le jeu vidéo youtube
heures car j'étais jalouse et argent
vous devez jamais depuis j'ai changé de
place une seule belle elle est vraiment
sortent d'où un peu plus journée se
passe bien et à mener à bien ou bien
écoute on va attendre ce qui va se
passer on est content d'être à barcelone
d'un vrai que tu m'avais dit de venir je
désire venir j'étais tanné ça te dit
reviens barcelone mais là pour le coup
je ne peux pas déçu vraiment de la ville
de barcelone
alors je comprends totalement espagne où
on va aller boire des bières en sortant
la salvetat pas faire comme ça fait
longtemps que je produis 2019 mais
notons en passant que tu vois ce qui
maintenant je poste ici
avec ton côté et bien sûr payer mais tu
vas te faire virer avec tout ce que tu
dis je suis dans la merde et d'autres
pensent toujours être là parce que
j'aime le risque
l'amour de risques c'est pour toi tu
risques exacts et johnatan nadia nuffer
les amoureux milliardaire du disque
tenait jennifer tu as l'air dépité
tu te crois barcelone regardez ce que
j'ai là le nouveau smartphone de ben
ouais c'est le huawei mais x s c'est le
petit frère du mythique ce qui était
présenté l'année dernière alors
smartphones qui a été renforcée
smartphones dont on a déjà vu un petit
peu l'adn l'année dernière lorsque été
présenté mais j'aime bien ce que tu vas
en plus les dernières je n'ai pas pris
en main ça je trouve ça plutôt bien
j'aime bien le l'idée le concept du
smartphone donc l'idée aujourd'hui c'est
de le découvrir de le prendre en mains
de voir un petit peu qu est ce qui peut
nous apporter quels sont les usages
qu'est ce que propose réellement ce we
meet xss qu'il est bien est ce que vous
pouvez l'acheter est-ce qu'il est fait
pour vous ils n'ont pas commun voilà
comment ça se passe voilà donc un petit
but alors là je vous la présente elle
est ouverte regarder hop je la fais
impôts vous le voyez comme ça en fait le
smartphone quand il est fermé
est ce que j'ai une gueule envers gelé
probablement bien le faire il se
présente comme un smartphone un petit
peu standard vous voyez un écran bon
voilà le format standard sarah grand
classique
l'écran du dos vous ne pouvez pas
l'activer vous pouvez uniquement
l'activé avec la caméra je vais vous
montrer
et après vous avez petit bouton rouge
vous appuyer là et c'est là que la magie
opère alors à l'arrière se passe
absolument rien vous avez juste le
module photo je vais vous montrer dans
quelques instants comment ça marche et
là vous retrouvez votre smartphone votre
grand smartphone avec votre grand écran
elle vient tu as des questions
on va discuter bien à côté de moi je
veux
ou tu me vois ouais je vois le manipuler
alors soit on y va tout petit peu tout
est au top
ok donc là tu nous présente enfin vous
nous présenter un tout nouveau produit
qu'est ce qu'il raconte comme histoire
produit alors il raconte la suite d'un
produit à succès de l'année dernière
les ânes et x au silence et à barcelone
avec quelques améliorations notamment au
niveau physique avec une nouvelle
charnière la charnière c'est un point
d'amélioration qu'il fallait travailler
sur par prometic ordinaire c'est un au
retour qu'on a eu chez nos consommateurs
donc quand vous voyez ici on la
solidifier donc on a gardé déjà la
promesse de garder cet écran qui vont se
mettre dos à dos oui puisque c'était
c'était le point fort du myhtique comme
l'année dernière donc l'écran est
toujours dos à dos et les badges arrière
supplémentaires ok bien à la fois se
courber à la fois étaient d'accord mais
qu'est ce qu'elle va apporter de plus
peu importe puisque effectivement on
s'en rend pas compte comme ça
concrètement on a un vrai point de
solidité qui a été rajouté en plus qui
avait rejeté en plus là où avant on
était sur un petit peu une maille de
montre également une tige qui va
vraiment parcourir tout le tout
l'appareil ont vraiment tenir le
solidifier à la fois quand on ouvre bien
d'accord à sion pourquoi on a gardé ce
format là c'est pour maximiser vraiment
l'expérience utilisateur c'est vrai
aujourd'hui
on va avoir un besoin d'être sur
certains sites web
un peu plus de vue sur une page web par
exemple on va avoir la même chose sur la
partie vidéo ce qui a été présenté par
exemple la possibilité dans les joues en
ligne écoutons de jeu un petit peu
différent donc vraiment une amélioration
de la productivité ou du nasa ok sur un
format qui reste contenue puisqu'on va
essentiellement la même chose à savoir
que vous avez si tout une charnière qui
fait à base de zirconium
bon je pense que mon côté un peu
technique mais en fait c'est petit bar
vous avez là et que vous avez l'autre
côté elle traverse intérieur pour une
vraiment solidifier le produit et les
rigidifier pour éviter qu'on puisse
venir casser vous avez ici un écran de 8
pouces vous avez sur ce côté là un écran
de 6 pouces
oui je les petites diagonales et à
l'arrière c'est un écran de 6,38 pousse
donc je vous montrais l'idée c'est que
tu as qu on le prend au louvre comme ça
on a le grand écran vous pouvez appuyer
là vous avez vos caméras l'arrière alors
ici y'a pas de caméra de cellfish si
vous voulez profiter de la caméra telle
fille il faut refermer l'histoire là
vous êtes toujours sur la caméra arrière
vous appuyer là ça vous demande de le
plier de le tourner et là vous arrivez
sur la caméra de ses deux filles pendant
ici une caméra 40 mégapixels c'est la
caméra principale qui me semblera de
faire vos photos je dirais un petit peu
standard qui ouvre à f 1.8 en
équivalence 27 mm vous avez en dessous
un téléobjectif de 8 mégapixels
équivalente 80 mm qui ouvre à f 2.4 et
évidemment stabiliser on est en dessous
un ultra grand angle qui est planqué la
la voyez juste celui là de 5 mégapixels
équivalence 17 mm qui ouvre à f 2.2 et
puis en dessous vous avez la petite
caméra et of time of light qui est là
pour le flou d'arrière plan qui a pour
mesurer la distance entre le smartphone
et l'objet d'un capteur de profondeur
qu'on nous annonce un réseau jusqu'à 200
4800 pour des photos en table luminosité
tout ça il faudra bien évidemment
pouvoir le tester un zoom optique x 3 et
un zoom numérique jusqu'à x 30 de la
macro jusqu'à 2 5 cm est bien évidemment
une stabilisation optique mais également
numérique en termes d'usagés rats qui se
destine ce parce qu'effectivement tuent
ils nous le montrent dans la presse on
va qu'on s'adresse à du gaming en pour
la partie visionnage mais on est quand
même sur un produit qui coûte quand même
quasiment 2500 euros c'est pas un
produit qui va destiner à tout le monde
qui est ce que vos cibles et
qu'aujourd'hui on va avoir à la fois la
cible des personnes qui veulent avoir la
dernière technologie dans la poche ouais
c'est assez important ils sont nombreux
ils sont nombreux et donc du coup on va
alors je peux les appeler les geeks
puisque généralement il n'aime pas ça
mais on va dire les technophiles
oui donc là vraiment découvrir découvrir
un nouveau format découvrir ses
applications avec une autre d'être une
autre avec de nouvelles vues oui jouer
avec un plus grand écran jouer en ligne
avec un plus grand écran donc du coup ça
va être vraiment c'est technophiles et
derrière les personnes qui vont aux
besoins de productivité un petit peu
accru la personne qui vont avoir besoin
à la fois de lire leurs mails et de
faire leurs propres et à côté tout ça en
mobilité
et là il y en a beaucoup aussi qu'ils
vont pouvoir tout ça tourne sur le
regarder la gelée comme ça ici alors
j'arrive à la voir
lorsque tu ça c'est marrant ça veuillez
passer de l'autre côté devises sur
l'autre écran donc en fait lorsque je
suis comme ça sans l'autre écran
attendait commenge faire alors il faut
que je louvre une fois que je louvre
peut-être un petit bug os
lorsque je le suis comme ça je le ferme
j'arrive là là je viens c'est impossible
de la voir mais pour l'avoir là en fait
ok il ya un petit accès une tête un
petit bug à corriger
je passe sur la caméra de celle ci je
mets la ensuite je ressors et en suisse
que naviguer là bon il n'ya pas grand
intérêt de ce seuil est tout petit mais
ces petites astuces et c'est possible
tout ça tombe bien évidemment sur le
dernier sac de riz silicone c'est le
keirin 997 un modem 5 j'ai donc c'est
effectivement un smartphone que vous
pouvez connecter en 5 g et ça c'est
plutôt cool
alors l'idée du kiri 990 et
qu'effectivement et bien il vous
apportera plus de performance d'une
meilleure autonomie puis avec la 5g une
collectivité toujours plus rapide pour
vous connecter à internet romero
naviguer sur faire faire à tout ce que
vous voulez surtout connectés plein
d'objets ensemble donc ça c'est plutôt
bien en termes de performances on est
comme sur un mec 30
exactement d'accord c'est la même chose
sauf qu effectivement ces deux facteurs
qui veut exigeante exactement haut
parleur mono monsieur oui d'accord
pourquoi par haut-parleurs stéréo sur le
côté un peu en craignant qu'ils ont des
contraintes des contraintes de taille
contrainte un peu technique de taille on
a un chargeur de 55 watts qui vous
permettra de le recharger
2-0 à 85% en 30 minutes le scm u10 qui
tourne sur un android disent bien
évidemment ici sans licence google tout
un peuple à la même problématique pour
vous l'autonomie c'est quoi là dessus
alors ça va dépendre des visages toute
façon chez huawei en a on est toujours
très fort en autonomie vous laisserez le
tester journée tranquille d'accord de
bonne journée donc votre journée de
votre journée qu est-ce qu on n'arrive
pas à deux jours bonne journée pour les
pour les utilisateurs qui seront à
prendre un peu hardcore no whine pour
quelqu'un qui fera uniquement de la
lecture mais les du suivi de ces santons
sans forcément avoir d'applications
énergivores l'écran ni sur quoi c'est
sur une dalle un peu plastique mais
c'est une belle plastique de deuxième
génération d'accords amiables avec en
plus une protection dessus pour la
partie révoquée en termes de robustesse
là dessus est ce qu'on a une
certification
alors il n'y a pas de certification
dessus c'est mieux pour éviter
on peut faire du multitâche voulait
s'appuyer vous avez votre petite appli
sur le côté avoue sexuelles et celles
que vous voulez allez on va commencer
par quoi par les fichiers ça vous le
propose comme ça on va se le mettre en
grand comme ça on a ouvert nos fichiers
attendait ça s'arrête pas là on ouvre on
appuie on va dire mais quand une petite
calculatrice on peut choisir de se
mettre comme ça et on va là disposer
comme envisat it calculatrice hop on
prend on se la met sur le côté on se met
une autre petite calculette si on
souhaite et on peut continuer sur ça
avec une troisième application
j'ai pas encore le coup je pense que
c'est pas très compliqué mais voilà nos
troisième application qu'est ce qu'on se
dit allez on se met une petite galerie
bon allez je suis pas encore un champion
là-dessus menons pas mal de choses donc
non sur le principe pourquoi pas de
toute façon les grands écrans comme ça
ça pour le multiapplication on le voit
pouvez faire ce que vous voulez
travailler l'utiliser du centenaire ça
c'est cool on en fait de manière réelle
de l'utiliser c'est ouverts et fermés ça
c'est juste pour venir prendre des
photos il n'y a pas un usage qui est
énorme si ce n'est effectivement de
d'agrandir la surface
la caméra pourquoi pas moi je trouve
bien il a coûté très sérieux ce
smartphone en fait il est un peu lourd
il a un côté vraiment très très
résistant très sérieux le petit bouton
pour venir l'allumé l'acquis également
les quatorze d'empreintes digitales le
petit bouton de volume ou y'a pas
beaucoup beaucoup de
bouton vous le recharger ici en usb ces
essais un smartphone qui coûte la
modique somme de 2499 euros en version 8
gigas de ram et 512 giga de stockage
voilà donc pour cette présentation
rapide de ce wake xs dites moi ce que
vous en pensez
j'ai peur ma caméra son mérite est très
pratique quand on fait ça comme ça
j'aurais dû prévoir un pied sérieux je
sais j'aurais dû mais non j'ai pris mon
petit à gori apod que voulez-vous sur
des tables comme ça ça bouge c'est pas
très pratique voilà donc alors on
reprend pour cette petite presse moi je
trouve je trouve cool j'aime bien ce
format il faut que le format est assez
intéressant l'idée effectivement du
smartphone que vous allez ouvrir comme
ça c'est bien
maintenant il ya des questions qui
peuvent se poser sur visage de l'écran
derrière la caméra ok je suis d'accord
forcément d'autres usages derrière à
côté de ça le produit est bien pour
plutôt pas mal à tester ça c'est
vraiment un truc à tester un peu plus
longtemps pour se rendre compte des
usages que le fait de se dire un peu le
côté un peu l'effet waouh du produit bon
il ya l'effet waouh
il ya un côté vraiment extrêmement
sérieuse sur la prise en main est sûre
le la finition du produit donc ça c'est
extrêmement rassurant
beau travail de la part de huawei
maintenant il ya plein de questions qui
vont se poser justement au niveau des
applications de oui mais ça on va
reparler d'ici quelques jours parce
qu'effectivement huawei se positionner
en concurrent direct au niveau du côté
applicatif de google bien évidemment
d'apple d'une alternative qui est
différente qui est intéressante
on va suivre ça de très très très très
près vous invite donc à vous abonner si
ce n'est pas déjà le cas mais c'est des
jolis coups des commentaires si vous
avez des questions grade et qu'on peut
le mettre comme ça on peut le tourner on
est sur 1,8 pouce de tous les côtés
bafoussam a rempli ce parce que vous
avez pensé comment vous le trouvez est
ce que vous trouvez ça intéressant parce
que c'est une proposition de valeur qu
intéressante café huawei là dessus est
ce que vous voyez vous les usages sur le
côté un peu multitâche d un regain de
vigueur mais ce conte et moi je trouve
ça bien sûr le principe j'aime bien
l'innovation est là l'innovation
intéressante c'est un des points forts
de la part de west c'est vraiment
l'innovation pour positiver toujours un
petit peu aux oiseaux fuck lors des
annonces et là dessus on y est
clairement voilà moi tout ça coule pas
ce que vous en pensez en bas
on s'envoie de l'amour on se retrouve
demain des bisous
hier
[Musique]